an online site lists nearly
50 awards that george martin has won
over the years
including multiple emmys for game of
thrones
several years ago time magazine
named george martin one of the 100
most influential people in the world
so it truly is an honor in this medal's
centennial year to introduce a master
storyteller
my own madeil graduate school classmate
from the year of 19
well well george if it's okay with you
let's just say
from a while ago dr
george r.r martin
thank you
thank you for those kind words professor
boy
and thanks as well to the dean and the
faculty
for inviting me to speak today it's
always a pleasure
for me to return to northwestern
something i've done
far too seldom since i left evanston
and after a year in quarantine it is a
thrill just to get out of the house
it has been half a century
since my own graduation but my memories
of northwestern remain fresh
i still recall those words of that song
from the
wam you show how's it go
the football games the dances the
serious romances
the parties when we didn't get home till
dawn
now i did attend a lot of football games
at old dyke stadium
most of which we lost i'm not likely to
forget that
my father who loved to gamble on sports
felt a moral obligation to bet on
northwestern every week since his son
was a student there
in the end i think his losses may have
added up to more than the cost of my
tuition
the dances though sorry don't dance
i did have a couple of serious romances
got my heart broken twice
on this very campus transposed into the
future on alien worlds
those relationships form the emotional
core of a number of my early stories
bleed onto the paper harlan ellison once
said and
it worked for me as for the parties
where they didn't get home till dawn
alas
i never got my invitations
i do remember my friends and classmates
well
some of them at least i remember the
dorm i lived in
the north shore hotel still standing
i remember my teachers
ben baldwin peter jacoby
james stacy neil mcneil
and bergen evans whose class was so
popular that he filled tech auditorium
year after year i doubt
that professor evans ever knew my name
but he had a profound effect
on my life and my writing all the same
i remember the chess team i captained
we won more often than the football team
but never managed to take down the
university of chicago
as for football i remember when the
student body voted to change the name of
the wildcats
to the purple haze somehow
that didn't stick my years in
evanston were the years that history has
taken to calling
the turbulent sixties there may have
been dances and parties but the
protests were more visible marches
demonstrations strikes rallies sit-ins
love-ins all of it reaching a crescendo
when the student body rose up
against the invasion of cambodia and the
murders at kent state
and tore up the wrought iron fences from
one end of campus to the other
to erect barricades transforming
sheridan road into something akin to the
streets of paris during the french
revolution
for about a week
not long after i found myself standing
with the rest of the class of 1971
where you are standing now diploma in
hand
about to depart medial and begin what my
father called
real life some of my classmates
departed for jobs on newspapers great
and small
others began careers in radio television
and film
joined an advertising agency or the
staff of a magazine
or found employment with uncle sam
over in vietnam the war was still raging
and boys unlucky enough to have had
their birth date pulled in the draft
lottery
found themselves faced with an offer
they could not refuse i got one of those
offers myself
but i had been granted conscientious
objector status
had my application been denied well
no one knows for certain what lies at
the end of roads not taken
but i don't doubt that you can find the
names of some of my classmates
engraved upon that big black wall in
washington dc
i was luckier doing two years
alternative service with vista
in chicago nights and weekends i wrote
science fiction
by the end of my service i had sold a
dozen stories
and had even been nominated for an award
i
lost i never did end up getting a job
reporting the news
instead i made a career making up
stories about aliens
and dragons and vampires i can almost
picture some of my old professors
shaking their heads and wondering how i
went wrong
a couple of my colleagues fellow writers
of science fiction and fantasy
like to call themselves professional
liars
i get to joke but it's not one i tell
myself
yes my stories are all about people who
never lived
doing things that never happened in
places and times that have never existed
but i like to believe there are truths
in them nonetheless
truths about life and love
good and evil and the human heart and
conflict with itself
the only thing worth writing about
according to william faulkner
but a novelist truth and a journalist
truth
are two different things and my fictions
have
certainly done well for me winston
churchill once said
a lie gets halfway around the world
before the truth has a chance to get its
pants on maybe that accounts for it
my lies flew on the wings of dragons
america was bitterly divided when i left
northwestern in 1971.
america is bitterly divided today
many of the issues that sparked protest
and dissension in 1971
remain issues today racism
we called it civil rights back then
sexism
in 1971 the term was women's liberation
income inequality back then we spoke of
poverty
but the biggest issue the fault line
through the center of american society
back then was the war in vietnam
unlike today the fight over vietnam did
not break down
on strictly partisan lines there were
hawks on the democratic side
among them lyndon baines johnson himself
there were doves among the republicans
who
men who wanted us out of vietnam people
could and did
change their positions in the end
that was what the marches and
demonstrations and protests were about
changing minds i was one of those whose
minds
was changed i came to northwestern in
1966
as a patriotic crew-cut high school kid
out of new jersey
convinced that we had to stop communist
aggression
that if we did not fight the vietcong in
vietnam
in a few years we would surely be
fighting them in the streets of bayonne
or evanston it was not any speech
or march or protest that began my
transformation
it was a class assignment a paper i had
to write about the origins of the war
the deeper i delved into the history of
vietnam and the american involvement
there the more
uncomfortable i grew this was not the
story i had been told
the real story did not fit with my
vision of america
and the ideals i thought she stood for i
did not want to accept it
but i had no choice the history was too
convincing
it was the facts that changed my mind
facts a short word a simple concept
truth has a grander ring to it i will
admit but
truth is a tricky thing a lot goes into
deciding
whatsoever things are true given the
same
facts even honest well-meaning and
reasonable men
and women may arrive at different
conclusions
each finding his own truth
but facts are the foundation on which
all truths must rest
unless you get your facts right you have
no hope
of arriving at the truth no doubt
everyone here is familiar with the medal
f some of you may have had a closer
acquaintance with it than you would care
to admit
that term was not in common use back in
the 60s as best i recall the first time
it came to my attention was years after
my graduation
i was certainly familiar with the
concept however
no matter how deft you're writing how
insightful your analysis
how skillful your interview techniques
if you got the facts wrong
even a single fact a single small
inconsequential trivial fact your story
was worthless
readers who noticed your mistake would
lose trust in the whole story
what if the rest of it was wrong too
readers who missed your error
would be misled neither outcome is
acceptable
falsehoods are never acceptable in a
news story whether intentional
or unintentional as mark twain once said
a lie can travel halfway around the
world while the truth
is putting on its shoes and yes
i did get a medal f myself only one
i'm pleased to say and it did not travel
anywhere
it may well be because of that lesson
learned long ago at mcdill
that i am so fearful of where we are
today in this country
in this world i would never have guessed
that the united states
could ever become more divided than it
was in 1971
yet somehow we have achieved that
when i look about today i cannot help
but hear the words of william butler
yates
and turning in the widening gyre the
falcon cannot hear the falconer
things fall apart the center cannot hold
mere anarchy is loosed upon the world
the blood-thin
tide is loosed and everywhere the
ceremony of innocence is drowned
the best like all conviction well the
worst
are full of passionate intensity
there was a time not so long ago when
journalism was
the center of our national life we all
read the same newspapers and magazines
we watched the same television shows
they defined us they united us they were
as much a part of the united states as
baseball
apple pie and the fourth of july and we
trusted them
when walter cronkite would end his
nightly broadcast with
and that's the way it is the country
believed him
liberal readers might not have liked
what they read on the editorial page of
the chicago tribune
conservative readers would bristle at
the editorials of the new york times
but the news on the front page was so
unquestioned
the news was the news the facts we got
from cronkite on cbs
were the same facts that chet huntley
and david brinkley were discussing on
nbc
watergate came along only a few years
after my graduation
nixon resigned in disgrace woodward and
bernstein became heroes
and applications rose at every
journalism school in the country
including media
you don't need me to tell you that those
days are gone
broadcast news has become hopelessly
politicized
network news divisions once considered a
public trust
have been absorbed into the
entertainment divisions
opinions previously confined to the
editorial pages
have crept into news columns and
newspapers after newspaper across the
nation
the concept of objectivity belongs on
the endangered species list
and all of this has eroded the public's
faith in the journalists who bring us
the news
you my friends the class of 2021 we'll
have to bear the brunt of all of this
as super chicken was want to say you
knew the job was dangerous when you took
it
daniel patrick moynihan once said
everyone is entitled to his own opinions
but no one
is entitled to his own facts a truth
that i fear much of the modern world has
lost sight of
when i hear supposedly respectable
political figures talking about
alternative facts my blood runs cold
your opinion may differ from my opinion
your truth may not be my
truth but facts are facts
are facts ricky gervais in a sort of uh
postscript to moynihan's famous
statement said
opinions don't affect facts but facts
should affect opinions and do if you're
rational
but are we john milton once said
the truth and falsehood grapple whoever
knew truth to be put to the worst
in a free and open encounter his
aeriopogitica
one of the oldest and most eloquent
defenses of the concept of free speech
was another text i was introduced to
here at mcdill
one that i have often quoted and taken
inspiration from
in the decades since but
john milton never had a twitter account
and he never met joseph goebbels the
brilliant of twisted propaganda minister
of nazi germany
grebels did not invent lying but he
certainly perfected it as an instrument
of state
if you tell a lie big enough and keep
repeating it people will eventually come
to believe
it grebel said a lie told once
remains a lie but a lie told a thousand
times
becomes the truth i would like to tell
you that milton was right
that goebbels was wrong but then i look
about me and i wonder
we seem to be living in the age of the
big lie tens of thousands of my fellow
citizens
actually seem to believe that hillary
clinton ran
a cannibal pedophile ring from a pizza
parlor in washington d.c
and millions seem convinced that last
year's election was stolen
though there is no shred of evidence to
support that
during the course of my career as a
science fiction writer and fantasist
i've written stories about ghosts
alien intelligences fast and light
starships
vampires and dragons wild fantastical
things
but none half so unlikely as the
sinister global conspiracies
that a large portion of the population
seem to believe
are real will the future prove
john milton right or does tomorrow
belong to joseph goebbels in the big lie
that i think may be up to you guys
the profession you're entering is not
one greatly esteemed by most of your
fellow citizens alas
recent polls show that journalists are
considered slightly less trustworthy
than bankers by most americans
just a few percentage points ahead of
lawyers
mind you there's still rank higher than
used car salesmen and members of
congress
but still my fellow screenwriters have
played a part in that
when was the last time you saw a
journalist portrayed favorably in a
movie or television show
it's been a long time since lou grant
these days you only see reporters in the
obligatory mob scene on the steps of a
courthouse
screaming and shoving their microphones
at some poor sod
while shouting inane questions instead
we get
more cop shows lawyer shows reality
shows
society finds its heroes in its stories
journalists can be heroes have been
heroes
and i hope will be heroes again
it is a heroic thing i believe to find
the facts
and tell the truth especially when those
truths are
unpopular and inconvenient
in recent years the word gatekeeper has
taken on a negative connotation
one that i believe is wholly undeserved
there was a reason why so many of the
cities and towns of the ancient and
medieval worlds were walled
and it was not to provide picturesque
ruins for tourists to stroll upon
the night was dark and full of terrors
and the gatekeepers
the guards were there to keep them out
today's social media have given us a
world largely without gatekeepers
and the trolls have all come out from
under the bridges to bedevils
our divisions go deeper and more
rancorous every year
there is so much information so much
misinformation out there
so many falsehoods and as edgar ellen
poe once said
a lie travels around the world while the
truth
is putting her boots on how can we hope
to come together again
to trust with facts
i say that is where it all begins i
never wanted a journalist to tell me
what to
think i could think for myself just
give me the facts does that sound easy
far from it it was never easy and it
grows harder every year
a few years after my own graduation when
i had finally reached a point where i
had a little disposable income
i made what was for me an extravagant
purchase
i bought a set of the encyclopedia
britannica
all that knowledge in one place an
essential tool for
any writer the other essential tools
being a good dictionary how to lie with
statistics
and the elements of style by strunk and
white
that encyclopedia served me well for a
long long time
but a while back observing the dust that
had gathered on top of the books
i came to the realization that had been
years since i had last opened the volume
a larger repository of human knowledge
had displaced it
the internet these days like most of the
human race when i need to know something
i google it's so much quicker so much
easier
and there's more information to be found
online than in all the encyclopedias
ever printed
put together and that would be wonderful
if only so much of it was not well
wrong those of you who have been paying
attention may have noticed that i have
returned three times to that quote about
a lie traveling halfway around the world
what truth is putting on
its pants or sneakers or boots
words that i have variously attributed
to winston churchill
to mark twain to edgar allan poe
who actually said that you may ask all
of the above perhaps
try none of the above
the line is most often attributed to
mark twain but according to quote
investigator.com
it does not turn up in any of his
writings and there is no record of him
ever having uttered those words during
any of his speeches
churchill never said it and poe really
does that sound like poe to you if a lie
was traveling around the world in pose
time it was traveling by horseback
these days lies travel at the speed of
light thanks to the internet
that's where i found all of these uh
what shall we call them misquotations
you can find them too they're still
there just type in a paraphrase of the
saying with quote
and it will all pop up with little
pictures of whoever is being credit
being given credit for saying those
words they are
wrong mind you but they're still there
and there they will remain for years
for decades for centuries
a thousand years to now if humanity has
spread to the stars some future internet
will tell us that mark twain once said
oh i will jump to the horse head nebula
while truth is putting on a space suit
the internet is forever its errors are
forever the internet is the greatest
depository of human knowledge in the
long
sordid and glorious history of our race
but is also home of the big lie
and a thousand little lies along with
millions of innocent mistakes fumbles
and bumbles we should do better we can
do better
we have to do better if we ever hope to
build a better world
you cannot build on a foundation of
mistruths
will we do better that i think is up to
you
and all the other young men and women
leaving college around the nation and
the world
my generation the class of 1971 had the
specter of vietnam
hanging over us as we left campus your
generation
faces a different sort of struggle a war
for truth
for facts for the soul of a nation
in the words of another of my heroes
stan lee
with great power comes great
responsibility
good luck to all of you
thank you
you